until 1963. Public Schools taught the  Bible and banned pornography  since 1963 public schools ban banned the  Bible and increasingly teach pornography  if you have not come across the  children's book genderqueer which is a  pornographic comic book by someone named  Maya kababi consider yourself lucky  unfortunately your children are not so  lucky very likely many of them have come  across that book in their high school  and middle school libraries  much as we might wish to dismiss this  whole debate with some platitude about  Free Speech the question cannot be  avoided because the schools have to  teach something  if the schools teach biblical morality  then they can't teach genderqueer  morality  if the schools teach genderqueer  morality they can't teach biblical  morality